hey
uh welcome everyone to day two of our ai
humanity workshop
um the first panel this morning
uh
we'll
be starting off with um sarah sen who is
at mit
and i will i will be keeping time
everyone has 15 minutes i'll give you a
five minute warning
okay great just checking if
everyone can hear me okay
all right thank you good morning um
today i'm gonna be talking about
the design and governance of human
facing algorithms and just to give a bit
of background my name is sarah and
my home department is computer science
at mit
and my work generally focuses on kind of
two components of day driven algorithms
one is kind of the theoretical
underpinnings of the design of
algorithms and the other side is the
auditing and governance of them
and today i'm going to be talking about
a few works um and they're in
collaboration with some amazing people
andrew elias alexander madrid and nish
ragavan
so when i'm referring to human facing
algorithms what i'm referring to is
algorithms that directly affect or
interact with the decision subject that
is human
and
okay i can speak a little louder yeah
maybe
move my paragraph
great
um and i think i don't need to motivate
the reason why we need to scrutinize
these human facing algorithms this
audience but two reasons that we might
be interested in doing so
are that they're increasingly common
right they have this kind of very
uniquely wide and deep reach into our
lives and that's only going to escalate
with time
but the second which is what i'm going
to focus on today is that we weren't
quite prepared for human-facing
algorithms both on the design side and
in terms of governing so on the design
side we kind of rushed into this era of
big data we took algorithms that were
designed for other applications and we
co-opted them for human-facing
applications
and what that's meant is that we've had
a lot of unintended consequences come
out of the design side and we're kind of
catching up on the government side
so i'm asking today how can we better
design and govern these algorithms and
do this short in time not really going
to cover this broadly but i'm going to
focus on two approaches or two works um
the first is what we call trust and
recommender systems and this is going to
be on the design side and the second is
what we call the right to be an
exception and this is going to be on the
government side
okay so trust and recommendation
um i think a lot of us are familiar with
recommendation platforms but effectively
what these platforms do is they generate
a set or an option a set of options for
each user and so when i'm talking about
recommendation platforms i'm talking
about netflix yelp facebook tinder and
even family
so netflix is going to recommend you tv
shows or movies facebook's going to
recommend you content yelp is going to
recommend you places to go tinder is
going to recommend you individuals to
date and grandmother is going to
recommend different ways of maybe
phrasing your sentence
and our focus today is going to be on
the trust between a user and their
platform and i just want to emphasize
that we're not focusing on trust that a
user has in another user because that's
kind of a different field of study
we might ask well why do we care about
trust
and the short answer is because humans
not just platforms are adaptable and
strategic
so we often give credit to platforms for
being able to adapt to maybe changing
data changing times
and then to be strategic to optimize for
their own objectives
but we don't give that same amount of
credit to humans
at least on the design side
but humans have the ability to perceive
they can develop mental models of how
they think a system works and they can
then adapt and strategize how they
respond to that system
and this is a problem for platforms
why because algorithms weren't designed
to be human-facing
most algorithms and recommendation are
going to follow this general kind of
framework they're going to assume that
users have a fixed set of unknown
preferences
and that these preferences aren't
necessarily adapting
or changing with time and what they're
going to do is they're going to then
probe the user for certain feedback like
ratings or they're going to observe you
on different platforms or different
sites and they're going to use that to
kind of fill in or infer those unknown
fixed preferences
but like i mentioned before
in reality the data is not id missing
uniformly at random et cetera all these
assumptions that we commonly assign
to users in recommendation
um so actually going back a little um
maybe just to give a little bit of
context what we did was we kind of took
these inference algorithms that were
designed for different applications so
they started off being
um co-opted from the days when we were
using algorithms to estimate the
location of like a submarine or a
missile what we were doing was we're
maybe like sending out some radar pulses
and then we're receiving data back um
but you know each radar pulse isn't
going to be strategic one compared to
the next is going to behave relatively
similarly and so we developed the sort
of like language and tools to deal with
this kind of data source
but when it comes to recommendation
platforms users are the data sources
right they're main data sources and they
don't have fixed preferences they can
adapt and they can strategize
and the strategic behavior is going to
violate some basic assumptions um that
we assume in recommended uh
recommendation
so we have that recommendation
algorithms kind of weren't designed for
this two-way adaptability and strategic
behavior and the question is well what
do we do next
what our work is doing is it's kind of
asking algorithm designers to maybe
rethink this framework for the sake of
users and for the sake of their own
algorithm the punch line here is just
going to be that trust is going to help
align the interests when you have two
strategic parties
so what kind of phenomena are we talking
about here i'm just going to use two
silly examples to help kind of ground
our discussion
you might go to facebook you might see a
link you might actually be super curious
about clicking on that link but you
don't do it why maybe you think
last time i clicked on a link facebook
sent me or recommended me a ton of
things with this content and i don't
want that or maybe this is actually a
link to an article that has an opposing
view to your own and you don't really
want to see more of this type you're
just curious you want to read what the
other side thinks but you don't want to
see more of that in the future but
there's no way to tell facebook that so
you strategize you don't click maybe you
open in a cognito tab and you kind of
search it on your own
um
as another simple example let's say
you're trying to protect your privacy so
maybe you're on youtube and you like
this video you watch it you like it but
you don't know who youtube is sharing
that information with and so uh you
strategically adapt and you say i'm
gonna downvote this video even though i
like it just to kind of like mess up
youtube's recommendation a little bit
and what we're arguing is that this is
kind of a self-defeating cycle right you
as a user are going to strategize
if you don't trust your platform that's
going to corrupt the data which is
foundational to the recommender systems
algorithm
you um
so the platform then is going to realize
that they don't necessarily trust their
users and their clicks and they're going
to take more extreme measures so they
might for instance say i don't believe
your clicks anymore so i'm going to
look for data that's more in line with
my assumptions i'm going to track the
way you scroll down your feed and see if
you linger on certain pieces of content
that's going to be my new proxy instead
of your clicks
but users are going to realize
catch on to this they're going to
realize that this is happening they're
going to strategize yes again platforms
are going to take more extreme measures
and really who's winning from this
and so this idea that maybe
we need trust to kind of align the
interests and maybe stop this cycle is
not new um hardin um political scientist
wrote a book in 1991 about trust as
encapsulated interest
based on this idea that
um
you trust someone when you trust that
they're going to act in your interest as
well and so
the idea um that we're trying to build
on is
when you have two actors like a user in
a platform who are working so closely
together
you have
uh you need some kind of guiding forces
um you have this sort of like implicit
contract but you need some kind of
writing forces and the correct notion of
that here is going to be trust
so we've kind of
tried to
force algorithm designers to think um
about their algorithms assumptions but
can we actually change anything
concretely and what we offer alongside
this is a formalization
this formalization
um just uh
very bare bones
is an alternating game where you're
going to have a platform deploy
recommender system so that's a set of
recommendations maybe the user interface
that comes with it in response the user
is going to maybe click on some
recommendations or interact with that
recommender system
platform is going to observe how you
behave and respond to the recommender
system and they're going to deploy
another recommender system so we're
going back to step one
step two again and so on and so forth
and what this game theoretic model
allows us to do is one to explicitly
account for the fact that users have
their own agency and two it allows us to
actually quantify um
uh kind of what trust adds um and maybe
what you can call maybe the cost of
distrust and so for example using this
formalization we were able to capture
both examples i talked about before
and kind of pinpoint what goes wrong in
these scenarios
just a quick note that we don't assume
rationality in this game theoretic model
and just the last point is you might ask
why does formalization matter
we're going to argue that formalization
does really matter in this context
because without it the algorithm
designers are going to continue to
playing algorithms right and if we don't
account for this human agency then
they're going to continue to ignore the
role of that and that's going to be to
the detriment of themselves and the
users
because they're going to argue look
why should i change why should i account
for trust why should i account for
societal concerns because in reality i'm
doing the best that i can do i've proven
it
and this is saying well look actually
you didn't account for something when
you account for something that's not
necessarily going to be true so let's
maybe
rework this co-opted algorithm
so without much preamble i'm just going
to jump into the second one in the
interest of time
and this is um called the right to be an
exception this is an ongoing work with
minish ragavan and so
um any feedback is super welcome
especially from this audience since
we're kind of stepping a little outside
our comfort zone for this
okay so let's start with an example
um let's say you have an individual who
comes in for
health care um or medical care and they
have the symptom i'm gonna call it
symptom green
and most often the symptom is associated
with some common illness
but
in some rare
but extremely
fast-acting fatal cases it's the only
symptom that shows up in some sort of
fatal disease
you could take maybe think of two
approaches you could take in the
scenario one is i could treat this
individual
as
the average of statistically similar
individuals like in my data set or i
might say can i rule out exceptional
cases by running a test running a simple
test and saying thank you
um
that
just running a test and saying look uh
you don't have this it's going to be the
common illness we kind of have this
intuition here that there's this push
and pull between
the cost of running a test maybe the
inconvenience
but that it should be balanced against
the risk of harm to this individual and
how much that information that test can
give us
and this kind of
push and pull this balance the way that
we kind of intuitively think about this
problem is what's going to be argued in
the right to be an exception
and so
one thing i'd like to point out is that
exceptions are natural they're
inevitable they're always going to arise
and we're paying particular attention to
data-driven exceptions for two reasons
one is because statistical averages are
so fundamental to machine learning
anytime you see probability it's likely
that they're doing some sort of um
expected value which is effectively an
average anytime you see accuracy
accuracy is an aggregate measure
so i guess the main point i'd like to
make here is that anytime you have an
average-based fool but you have a
heterogeneous population you're always
going to get exceptions
the second is that data-driven rules are
non-intuitive
um i am not that's going to require a
slightly more involved discussion so i'm
going to take it if it's okay
um
so dangerous rules are non-intuitive um
you know
uh you can think of the autonomous
vehicle example let's say you have 10
fatalities per million without a ton of
stables and then you have one fatality
per million with autonomous vehicles and
you ask oh that's so much better that's
great but what if it was these 10
individuals who were the fatalities and
without autonomous vehicles and then all
of a sudden it shifts it doesn't reduce
it but it shifts to a different
individual when you add autonomous
vehicles and we don't really really kind
of
um have intuition for who that
individual is want to be that's going to
be harmed by this data-driven
change um and this non-intuitiveness is
why we need to have a special attention
here
um because i'd argue that in kind of
more human-raising applications
applications
human we know the limits of human
cognition
and we know where exceptions arise so we
know kind of how to account for those
and that's what often our legal systems
are doing
so the goal here is to provide legal
protections for individuals who through
no fault of their own fall through the
cracks when it comes to day driven
decisions
i'm a little bit running out of time
here so i'm going to go through this
super quickly
there are a bunch of reasons acceptance
arise this is kind of a little bit more
for the technical audience um it can
come from sampling bias modeling
capacity distribution shift partial
observability and many more and the
point i'd really like to make here is
just that it's not just that you lack
enough data about individual there are
multiple sources
that can cause this
the right to mean exception i'm not
going to be able to do a full treatment
here so i'm just going to identify the
three main factors which are
harm individualization and uncertainty
and so risk of harm
you can look to write to regional
inferences or
write to contest ai or
the proposed ai act
of the eu for kind of
um
ways to kind of ground this
thought process but risk of harm
provides a measurement stick it kind of
says look when should i be pursuing
action on behalf of my right to be an
exception
individualization is this kind of
natural thing that comes out of
if i'm using an aggregate rule i'm going
to have exceptions so maybe the problem
is i need to individualize my
decision-making process more
to
the individual of interest maybe i'm not
capturing all the relevant information
and so it shifts their attention from
aggregate to individual
but the one that actually is i think
really really important is uncertainty
and uncertainty captures kind of these
inherent limits the challenge is this
notion very common notion in computer
science that with enough data with
enough computation as t goes to infinity
as n goes to infinity that you can
estimate anything i'm going to argue
that actually ground truth isn't always
possible
so the reason uncertainty matters
you could argue that
skipping through a little bit
maybe it's just
i should individualize my decision if my
decision isn't individualized enough and
the risk of harm is high then i don't
deploy this decision and i'm gonna argue
that's not enough and the reason why is
because
you have different types of uncertainty
that arise one is epistemic and this is
uncertainty that is reducible you can
add features
that will eventually maybe refine your
algorithm refine your decision
so this results from lack of knowledge
but there's also aliatoric uncertainty
and this is irreducible knowledge that
comes from just inherent unknowability
so individualization is basically going
to tackle epistemic uncertainty but it's
not going to tackle allergic uncertainty
and i'm just going to end on a simple
example which is let's say you're using
a data-driven assessment to
inform parole decisions the approach
here is i'm going to predict whether or
not someone recidivates which is the
outcome
by comparing them to individuals in my
training data set that's effectively
um you know you might be rewaiting but
that's effectively what's happening
one of the problems we can identify here
is that we know that you know doing so
washes out the details that make a
defendant unique
and
then we might want to individualize we
might want to add features we want to
make it a bit more refined
but there's this second part
which is that what we're effectively
doing is we're having an individual be
judged based on the actions of others
and not their own so we're kind of
stripping them of their moral autonomy
this kind of like a moral determinism
that's happening here um and this is
what aliotouric uncertainty gets at
and i will conclude there thank you
[Applause]
all right so next up we have peter
hershak from the east west center